Film Courage: Logan for your career as a writer
would you be okay with a workload filled with
writing assignments for other projects,
polishes, rewrites, etc.? Then maybe just
do one or two more feature scripts for yourself
as long as it meant that you were a writer?
that you would be okay with what the
daily duties were, polishing, rewrites,
coming in adding a scene here
and there for someone else?
Logan Burdick, Screenwriter: I feel if you're
in anything, again whatever the profession,
so in this case if I'm a writer, what I
should love first and foremost is writing
and then obviously people diverge from
that right? Then they have a lot of very
specific concerns depending on who you are as an
individual but to me to the love of the action,
the love of the activity transcends everything
else. I think that sometimes the act, the activity
can be a more positive or negative experience
right depending on of all sorts of factors.
If there's the very the version that would
make me the most happiest if you're asking
if I got to wake up every day and I got paid
to write, would that make me happy? Absolutely.
My perspective is when you realize how difficult
it is to manifest that (not in these new age
ways) but to literally create that scenario I
think that it makes you just really appreciative
that you get to have that experience that's how it
is for me anyway again there are I think there's
there's movies or stories that I'm better at and
there's certain skill sets that again are more
unique to me for whatever reason that is that
I have a specialty in but if I but regardless
just the idea of getting up and writing is I to
me is a wonderful situation to find yourself in
what types of stories are you best at do you think
if someone came to hire you to do a rewrite
a Polish it's a increasingly this probably
I mean the James Gunn, Taika Waititi
camp where where it's these big genre
even these genre Adventure pieces but with this
undercurrent of Comedy I've accepted that that's
that that's what I do and it makes me happy to
do it I think there's always this idea where
you're oh I'd to do a Christopher Nolan movie
but I'm not Christopher Nolan I when I'm doing
a scene it needs to end on a punch line and if
it doesn't end on a punch line I get neurotic
about it I'm no there has to be what was the joke
and it's it doesn't always have to have a joke
but I think that that to me I’m glad that I
saw the new Suicide Squad a couple weeks ago
and I loved it and to me that's so exciting
because it's oh okay this is now this is a
sub-genre right because you have these incredible
people at the top of their game who are help help
shaping the conversation and you can look at that
and go oh okay there there is a place for this now
I think the whole the idea of inclusivity and
diversity and all those issues also feed into
that same idea which is when you can see examples
of the stories you want to tell or the skills that
you think you have there's an opening for that
now and you're okay people do that it wasn't
this isn't just a me thing right and so that's
that's a I think that's a cool thing that as
that as genre keeps diversifying into all these
there is a lot there's a much larger spectrum I
feel and that's exciting because then you can
look at that and you can say okay I think this
is where my voice fits in and then hopefully and
then hopefully you could find a way to get there
because it's still very hard what if someone asked
you to to do a rewrite on a an intense legal drama
feature film or a horror film that there was
no comedic elements too I think the thing that
this previously I would to get to a I I'm not that
person I should not be well it depends on what
it is but but intensely good legal drama no that
should not be me right and I and I think sometimes
you're in this weird position where you're if
you're not as established as you'd to be you
you take on things that are not the best fit
the goal is to try to get to a place where
where you can turn it down because it shouldn't be
you for whatever reason it shouldn't be you right
because I think that that doesn't do a service
to anyone ultimately any life story or project or
whatever should everyone should want it to be the
best version of itself that it could possibly be
and if it's not the right fit for you then it
should go to whoever it's the right fit for
I think it's a disservice to to everything to
try to to in that situation I guess sure okay
okay that makes sense that you feel that your
best self your best work would not be suited
for certain projects and just knowing that you're
okay with that and that you do your best work you
said these Adventure films with the comedic twist
that are light maybe lighter I was it was probably
darker darker okay maybe this is sorry there's
some dark sarcasm yeah interwoofing okay that
sounds good yeah the one thing I would add to that
is I do think that also to me to me it's sometimes
less about genre and more about the type of story
right because I also feel sometimes sometimes
it's not I feel any good writer can figure out the
conventions of a drum of a genre and do that well
I think that it's harder to put yourself in the
position of characters that you don't understand
and again I do think that a good writer should
have a lot of latitude and being able to imagine
that but I do think that there are there are just
limits and also with the other caveat being that
not only are there limits but also it's not
necessarily playing to your to your strengths
right where it's if that you understand this type
of character and I guess it hasn't really come up
for me but if it was illegal drama but it was oh
it's a legal drama storing this type of person I
go okay I do understand that better and so maybe
this makes sense to take a shot at sure the TV
show LA law that had humor to it whether it was
dark sarcastic humor but it wasn't this intense
depressing drama it was later and the characters
had more humor to them but yeah I see what
you're saying yeah I was gonna I have to take that
perspective because for instance on it takes three
I really enjoyed it there's all sorts of other
stories I want to tell and I've been fortunate
that any opportunities that have come since people
are able to look at the characters and the tone
and say oh could you take that and could you
put it in this situation with the genre could
be entirely different and that's and that's a
really great place to be because I don't think
I don't I think most people don't want to only
get stuck doing one type of one type of story
or maybe some people do I can't say for everyone.